Dancing with the Stars Pro Witney Carson
gives an update on her father-in-law's
health
[Music]
the 24-year old dancer took to Instagram
on Saturday to share with fans her
husband Kherson McCallister's father
Kevin is now in hospice care after
battling cancer for almost two years
Whitney posted this heartwarming pic
along with a note that read in part we
are devastated to share that Kevin's
body is no longer able to tolerate
treatment we are just cherishing every
moment we have with him as unbearable as
this is we are thankful for the time we
have had with him I just wanted to say
thank you to everybody who has been
praying for Kevin and for our family I
know I don't post a lot of personal
stuff especially sad stuff in December
Kirstin announced that she would be
pulling out of the Dancing with the
Stars winter tour to be by her husband
and family side during this hard time
it's been really heartwarming that
everybody has been so gracious and
supportive
[Music]